hello everybody hope that you're good
last week I didn't upload a video
because I was in a live stream my first
ever live stream and I don't think I did
that bad guys I don't know what you
think but yeah it was in twitch it was
in the channel of my friend FY so you
can watch on replay I'll leave it in I
leave the link in the description in
case you want to and yeah that was last
Friday it was a bit long 2 hours and a
half so only watch if you have a spare
time because in this video is going to
be you know the latest to date that I
have for you so yeah I mean feel free to
watch if you want to know more about me
a lot of questions were ask in the chat
so um I answered to to all of them that
I could and yeah it was very fun so
thank you follow for the invitation
again if you're watching this uh maybe
one day you come to the channel who
knows anyway the let's talk about
Bitcoin Bitcoin so far what I'm thinking
well is something that we've been
anticipating for a few weeks already and
is very likely that we see some kind of
a range here between 90,000 okay that's
your 90,000 level especially I think
it's marked by by this week here that
we've got in the 4our time frame because
if you go into the 4our time frame you
can see that week there that it's
perfectly marking those range lows okay
so I think that will be my range lows it
will be the end of that week and then if
you go again into the daily time frame
we should Mark that the Range High which
I think is has to be 100K a strong
psychological level I mean it's a round
number 99k is not the same as 100K even
sounds different come on so yeah I would
say that this is some kind of R range
environment that we could see for the
next few weeks and in my opinion likely
will last until around the 20th of
January that's 3 weeks from now on and
that would be basically around here from
here we could see either a breakout or a
breakdown from this range now I'll tell
you first why I think that around that
date makes sense and second what
direction I think it'll most likely go
to so the date is mostly because you
know we're in Christmas time H then it's
New Year there are not that many Traders
institutions out of work now is most
likely that we stay in this range
also you can see here has some support
with the daily 15ma and the 20th of
January is also the date of well the
official date of the inauguration of
Donald Trump as a new president of the
United States so who knows maybe from
that date we could start to see some
volatility all right so that's what I'm
thinking that likely we'll stay in this
range for the next two three weeks
likely okay uh we'll see about that but
the most important thing is about the
direction of the breakout and and I
think that you know this was some
consolidation in fact I think that this
was also a channel okay now this type of
channels after an uptrend they tend to
break to the upside because there was
here these highs that they were not hit
you have to go above these highs okay
there's a lot of liquidity there and
also above this trend line here there is
a lot of stop losses liquidations so to
me whatever made what what made the most
sense in the situation was a breakout to
the upside now we got that breakout we
got also the the support retest at the
top of the of that channel and
continuation this structure however is
very different I think is a a range okay
and usually a range at the
highs and especially in this context and
I'm going to explain why I think this is
most likely you know a leg up
consolidation and continuation another
leg up so I'm expecting a breakout
eventually from this range why well go
to the weekly time frame if you see a
range at the highs or some consolidation
at the highs usually a sign of a
reversal are weeks to the upside but
price not progressing any further all
right so if you notice here it's not
that you don't have that that you have
the completely opposite you have weeks
to the downside towards those r range
highs that with market and price is not
managing to break further to the
downside why well it seems that there is
some kind of intention that price stays
in this Zone all right so um so far the
chart to me looks bullish I can of be
bearish in high time frame here so yeah
playing level by level I don't think
that this is bearish at all I'm
expecting um the first 6 months of 2025
to be quite bullish I can also support
the theory in the S&P 500 I don't think
by the way and I've explained this
before I don't think that this fomc drop
was a terning point in fact I was
expecting this drop to get retraced very
fast which is what happened simply
because this drop didn't didn't happen
due to the dotplot didn't happen due to
the news it simply happened because you
don't power said in the in the press
conference that today was a two call and
of course you know if investors hear
that they're going to start to sell and
that turns into a ShakeOut not a turning
point because um if you look at the real
data The Dot Plot it's actually bullish
because it's expecting one extra rate
good than the federal funds Futures
Market was expecting they were expecting
only one and the FED is expecting two
rate goods for next year so in terms of
uh macroeconomy let's say which I'm not
an expert um but but I think that that's
not a turning point okay or it shouldn't
H signal a turning point it's true of
course that the dollar Index is breaking
out and yeah it looks quite bullish it's
going to the weekly time frame I also
said on the last on the last live stream
on Friday that it's likely that we go
and fill this liquidity pool here around
110 so yeah I mean we're not out of the
woods usually the dollar Index go going
up means that Bitcoin consolidates or
even drops okay so no expecting
fireworks yet for Bitcoin now if we go
back into the daily time frame let's
mark all the levels and all the
scenarios so my first scenario is that
um and I think that this is the most
likely this is a range
consolidation or a sideways move in an
uptrend that will lead eventually to a
breakout to another leg up okay but
there are few levels here to keep in
mind this will be the the the first one
okay that one line there 85k that's a
very key level because if you drop below
that level then you know you are
basically going to continue dropping at
least to 72k 72,000 is a level with a
lot of support so yeah that would be a
big drop also considering that if we
Mark the liquidity pools with my
indicator you can see there two three
liquidity pulls to the downside three
imbalances so yeah 85,000 it's the last
level that I would like to see holding
okay I need to see the level holding and
by the way if you want to access uh the
indicator um you can see that well it
marks the I'll show you very quickly
what it does is I've been working on
this for a many months now also in
January next month we're getting the
second version of the indicator which is
going to fix a lot of things and improve
a lot of things but basically in Max the
week F strategy the 50% and 100% of the
weeks also the liquidity pools has two
formulas that the next version we're
going to try to convert into one so
basically the settings look cleaner and
they don't overlap also H to each other
the daily 50 ma all right that you can
also change it to the time frame that
you want no matter which one you
currently are in and then you have also
here the trading sessions in case you
want to trade in in low time frame all
right so if you want to access indicator
it's now your time because we've opened
this new telegram group where basically
we're giving access to every single
person that has a bluffing account
registered under my referral link and
reaches a minimum of 50,000 trading
volume which is very easic because
includes leverage so in a few trades in
a few days you should be able to get it
even if you don't have much capital
because again includes leverage and the
important things I have to say is that
if you already have a bluffing account
that is registered under someone else's
referral link or is not registered under
any referral link doesn't really matter
you can DM me on on X or on telegram
aroba cryp noo and you can tell me your
uid and we can transfer that straightway
to my to my under my referral link so
then you can apply okay now once that's
done or once you have a new Bluffin
account okay then you have to click here
in this link and it'll take you to a
chat with a B that we've developed
ourselves and basically it's a bluffing
bot where you tell him your bluffing U
ID he verifies you automatically in the
moment he asks you for your trading view
username so we can give you access to
the indicator in trading view because so
far it's an invite on
indicator and he also gives you access
to a telegram channel that is new
where we're basically going to post
indicators updates and also some free
resources perhaps a book that I'm
writing right now I'll post it there for
for you guys and yeah some campaigns of
bluffing and bonuses and and stuff so
yeah guys feel free to do this and let's
continue charting cuz that's what I'm
good at really not telling you all about
this so so yeah I would say that the
daily time frame so far it looks good
nothing here of concern again my son of
concern would be if we lose 85,000 then
yeah that'll concern me a lot because
then we're probably going to drop there
um around 20% I think it is
272k so 15% drop that would be the next
thing if we lose 85k so hopefully we
stay in this range for now right now in
the 4-Hour time frame and this is where
the party starts uh because took a few
trades on this and I'm going to tell you
how um I'm I'm playing this and if you
are a day trader this is the part of the
video that is going to interest you the
most so basically if you guys remember
go to the 2 hours time frame we were
talking about two key levels here in the
last update that I did on X one was this
long wiek here the 100% level so that
would be 90k hang on what's Happening
Here I made a mistake one
second this long week there let me
change the
color there so yeah that long week the
100% level is 90k and then the other
idea that we had in mind was a potential
W view formation here okay something
like this now that's why I've mentioned
also in teram on the the fream channel
the way I was trading this so I
basically divided my entries I think
well I thought and I still think that
it's quite likely that we go to the 100%
of the week that's why here I have
50% 50%
here of my size okay so that's what I I
would be deploying 50% of my size if we
go to 90k I'll be looking to take that
trade with 50% of my size of the of my
position okay this is my risk management
then at this level here when we were
here we were talking about this
potential drop towards you know that
liquidity pull there because yes that's
a liquidity
pull and that's why at this level
here okay well basically at that level
there I had
20% of my position of my size that one
actually go triggered okay now with that
trigger I took some profits here at the
1 hour 50 Ma and also so well not not
that late I took profits again at the 4
50 Ma I don't have much of that position
so far because I think that it's very
likely that we go back towards the 100%
of the week okay where I can feel the
50% of my full size so yeah so far I
will probably have around
10% 12% of my total size because I've
taken some profits and then the rest 30%
is in case we can actually find
acceptance Above This level above 100K
so far we've only been hitting it with
weeks and been rejected so in the moment
that we actually can manage to find
acceptance about 100K that'll be telling
me that we're going to go higher that
we're going to go towards this level
and this is will be the level where I
will be deploying the remaining 30% so
I'm going to write it here down for you
okay this is so far H how I'm position
okay 20% Which I've already taking
profits here and here now I have around
10 12% left I think it's likely we go
back here towards the 90k level where
I'll be deploying 50% of SI and then if
we get acceptance of this level then I
go there 30% more to to deploy that will
be compounding my winning position if
that's the case Okay and then yes we can
expect higher prices so this is the way
that I'm U trading Bitcoin and I think
that we have to be quite patient because
if you notice you know the market is
moving quite slow We ranging there is no
rot but yeah in terms of Swing trading
and they trading executions I think
those are the best ones in my in my
opinion right now uh I think that's
pretty much everything I want to say in
Bitcoin so yeah just kind of waiting
kind of waiting for these days to to
pass where we want to have more
volatility in the next coming weeks
which I think is going to be a very good
time to trade that's give it two three
weeks or so and until then if we can
start to get into some good positions
like this then perfect okay even a
deviation below the 100% of the week is
very likely okay usually when you have
the 100% level of the week it's very
common to see those kinds of deviations
okay also here if you guys notice the
100% of the week it's really if we mark
it
exactly look guys exactly at
9,500 round number okay now if we
deviate slightly below it you're going
to hit 90k 90k is another psychological
level another round number even stronger
than
9,500 because it's a semi round number
and surely there is going to be a sell a
buy wall sorry and surely there is going
to be a b wall at that level I'm sure
that if we check the order book we can
see a lot of orders resting on those
levels so yeah if we deviate right below
it 90k could give was that kind of
Bounce okay so so far that's what I'm
looking at then of course let's see near
the time because we know that the market
maker kind is poof the order so if we
are getting close you know imagine we
are around 91k 92k that's the time
really to open the order book and check
what is happening with those orders are
they leaving them there that means that
they are real that they are going to
bounce that want to go and fil them and
bounce from them but if you start to see
those orders and 90k disappear in that's
SC is puffing it's a trick because you
know there are some Traders now that
open in the order book they see that 90k
there is a lot of buy orders so they
Place their at the same level hoping
that you know if everybody buys like me
we all going to make the price of
Bitcoin bound so
uh if right before hitting the level
those orders disappear then the price
you know doesn't get supported price is
going to continue dropping right so the
I'm not going to look at the order book
now I'll be looking at the order book
when we are close to that area okay if
it's the case that we actually drop
towards 92k 91k then that is the time to
open the order book all right not now so
yeah that's so far all I think about
Bitcoin guys now if we go and check for
example
ethereum ethereum really quickly look at
this guys weekly time frame you want to
notice something interesting here here
look at that level
4,000 you can even put AIT higher go to
the coordinates
4,000 that is your level psychological
level three rejection so far within two
or three candles if you notice at the
highs that's two candles price gets
rejected and drop sharply again here two
candles drops G three candles and drops
okay and the levels where we could drop
to I'll show them right on the daily
time frame but also in the weekly time
frame I want to say that what do you
guys think is going to be a signal that
price is going to go higher well simply
not to do this not to do this and not to
do this again if we start to actually
see price coming back up towards this
Zone and consolidating a bit longer okay
that is telling you that that's a change
of behavior and prices goes up is the
same as when the Bitcoin dominance was
ranging you're going to see the same
thing here guys look this was range
price hits here drops price hits drops
again here all the time but then here
you have a change of behavior change of
environment you see consolidation for a
few weeks that is telling you something
is changing breakout retest
continuation okay so looking for
something very similar in ethereum
and that would be the
consolidation below 4,000 or why not
this would be obviously even better and
a much clearer sign but if we actually
go above 4,000 and consolidate for two
three candles above it that is basically
a resistance support flip signaling
continuation to the upside which I think
would be around $5,500 all right so that
is what I'm paying attention to in
ethereum nothing else really in in terms
of breakouts and then if we actually are
going to drop the same as we did in the
previous time see you can see okay and
we are doing that right now two levels
you have first of all the quickly 50 ma
that level should be able to hold okay
and also in the daily time frame which I
think it's even much more interesting is
this look at this area here you got a
lot of support there okay very probable
very likely a slight deviation below it
we've been talking about this for weeks
it can still happen a SL deviation below
3,000 you know give me
2,980
2,940 maximum then get back above it
that will be your trigger and price can
continue going higher right so at least
to 4,000 that will be your first tech
profits and if you see the Breakout than
5,500 so this is the way that I'm
trading and the and the way that I'm
trying to get position for the next few
weeks could Bitcoin you know drop below
85,000 and go to 72,000 yes it's
possible but so far that is not what the
chart is telling me level by level we're
in a Range 100K to 90k all that matters
to me in Bitcoin is whether if we are
going to go what 95k so all I care about
is are we going to go to 100K first or
we going to go to 90k first that's all
that I care about right now as a day
trade okay I'm not thinking of 85k I'm
not thinking of 72k I'm not thinking of
130k that is not what I make
business what I make the most amount of
money and most amount of Trades is in
this type of environment here so yeah go
again to the range lows perfect give me
that deviation get up above above it
that would be a very safe trigger to
enter okay then take profits at the
range highs if you see a breakout then
continue riding those bus all right so
there is not much more to it let's
continue let's continue Bitcoin
dominance well this one this one is
quite tricky um with the Bitcoin
dominance to me is the most interesting
chart at the moment because it's the one
that yeah scares me the most cuz um I
have an idea of what it's likely going
to happen ball and you know Bitcoin
dominance behaves in such ways that
sometimes are difficult to predict so
far until here I've been able to read it
correctly but I'm scared that from this
point I might be wrong okay so really
quickly long story short you have here a
range for two years then well you see
here the change of behavior of
environment that we were talking earlier
that consolidation so we are expecting a
breakout a RIS test of the range SI
perfect continuation perfect fill up all
these inefficiencies all these
imbalances this liquidity pools then the
last thing this was 61. 55% that is the
level that I Mark we actually touch it
it perfectly I think we went even to
61. 70% so pretty much the same level
and I Mark that level basically because
I don't see any more inefficiencies or
inbalances to the upside so to me it
doesn't make much sense that price would
go higher than this level right so I'm
still thinking that that is likely the
top or again I'm quite afraid that I I
might be wrong about this but yeah so
far this could be some kind of
retrace continuation all right that's
what I'm keeping an eye on for the
Bitcoin dominance over the next 6 months
or so and my first level of support
would be
52% see how that behaves if we lose it
then you're going to go to the range
highs here 48% all right so that's all
that it is to me uh right now I'm scared
because we saw support at the weekly
50ma and I want to see that level ER not
holding I want to see that level
breaking okay so we could go all the way
to 60% which is what I initially spotted
was some kind of M formation like this
but we actually went sharper than I
thought and then hopefully that's the
retrace and that's the continuation
right so that's my idea of the Bitcoin
dominance and consequently I'm looking
at altcoin so um for example Solana guys
what Solana I saw I said this also in
the in the live stream on Friday with
fies I was grunk about this had to take
a loss here because I was expecting the
previous high this jell line to hold we
were holding it for some time along the
daily 50 ma eventually we saw a spike up
in the Bitcoin dominance that I didn't
anticipate so Al coins took a took a
tumble dropped quite a lot there had to
take the loss and right now I'm paying
attention to what could happen next
which in my opinion is this white line
is quite interesting to me and it's only
interesting in the case that Bitcoin
drops to 90k okay if Bitcoin drops to
90k to the 100% level of that long week
that the range lows deviation goes up
okay remember that that scenario that
we've talked about if that is the case
with Bitcoin then Solana should drop to
to this white line there okay you can
see supports there very clear supports
and resistances all the time price
engaging in that zone nonstop all the
time you can see those kinds of
reactions so perhaps we're want to see
again and in the weekly time frame it
matches very well with the weekly 50ma
and I always say that in a bull
market one of the safest buy areas in a
sport is the weekly 50ma and that's what
I said in Solana here bought Solana at
$113 then we got the long week there we
said is going to get retrace so don't
worry don't buy yet here if you've
missed an entry before because you are
going to go back to the weekly 50ma cuz
it matches with the 50% level of the
week we got that again prices goes up
okay so um what I'm anticipating is that
if we drop to this white line again the
weekly 50 m also going act a support and
then price can continue going higher
that's basically what I'm expecting very
bullish in Solana so the next Alcon is
TA Soo I don't know how you guys say it
how is meant to to be set but I call it
how and with this one I was quite lucky
because I managed to get a very good
entry in a spot at these levels here
45ish didn't take any profits here I was
expecting to be honest to go to at least
$11,000 or so and then this happened
okay for some reason you know to went
absolutely to the floor look at this
long week it's huge and luckily I missed
it I didn't see that in life and I open
my my chart at this Zone here so imagine
you guys open your chart here and you
see this long week so what I did at that
at that moment was basically to sell all
my spot back that I had from this level
thinking that it was quite likely that I
was going a round trip on my back if I
didn't do that because you know long
weeks they tend to get filled so yeah I
luckily managed to sell all my spot back
there and so far I haven't bought again
I could have bought again at the same
level to be honest or even slightly
cheaper because they went to
$400 haven't done so already and to be
honest lack of um care I think I didn't
put alarms at 400 should have done that
or at least at the 50% level of this
week but what I'm thinking here for to
is that again if bit coin drops how far
can to go and the last the last level
that I would like to see holding really
strong is this sance line there okay
because you can see that should be quite
a strong support um we like to see to be
honest another potential drop here
towards this zone so you have one two
three TOS pattern reversal so um yeah I
think that Bitcoin drops to 90k which um
that's the scenario that I'm going more
with slightly more likely then you could
get there the third top reversal and if
we are looky then price could actually
go to this orange line where it's
cheaper and it's a stronger support and
you would have more confidence of a
bound so those are the two levels that
I'm looking in in to around $400 again
$45 $410 again and if we drop even lower
than 366 all right so those are my
levels for this Alin then chain link
chain link I was looking here also I
said in my last video that I was going
to sell 75% of my bus at
$30 look what happened at $30 price goes
to $30 weeks to upsite price not
progressing any further that is telling
you that price is been sold at the
highest level that the chart can find
that the market makers can sell those
ERS to the retail that are pro possibly
getting excited and saying look we are
back at 30 we can go to 40 right we can
go to 50 so that's where the big money
sells the back to the small money and
looky to have CAU that one and rode the
wave with the market maker that same
trade and right now I think that daily 8
could be a level that should be acting
as quite strong support so I think that
any Buys in this area are welcome uh
possibly we'll get back into chain link
if we get another Touch of this area and
you don't really want to see the
level and not holding because then I'm
probably going to go to around $17 which
is quite a big drop in comparison so
yeah looking really for this area here
to hold right we can maybe go back to
$30 after that so that's what I'm
thinking for chain link right now no I
would really like to get back
into and right now personally I would
I'm looking to get back into it CU I've
sold so it would be nice to buy again
cheap I mean price is already cheap but
I would like to see another retest of
that daily 50m at least so next coin is
Ina
okay this one is been trading very
strongly you can see very strong up
Trend one of the strongest Al coins
right now in the market it's amazing uh
got in at 33 34 cents sold most of my
bus too early around here around
4850 cents then sold again well B again
sold again right now I'm looking to
enter again um the place where I'm
looking at is right here okay it's daily
50a you can see that we are making this
area some kind of a strong support CU
here it was a very strong resistance
back at the time then strong support
support again another touch there to 85
cents would be the first one of the
daily 50 May and we could see some kind
of a bounce there back to $1 all right
so that is what I'm looking to reenter
in Ena and I'll do so if I get an
opportunity next one okay here I got for
you a couple Al that are very similar
very similar structure and is my
favorite structure in a bare Market okay
or in a transition between a bare and a
bull market and is this kinds of ranges
at the lows these
consolidations which really all there
are is accumulation ation accumulations
of of price you know before the next leg
up and then you're going to attack this
kind of key peot levels like 26 Cents
okay so um B here I myself at the
midrange and if we drop again to the
range lows then I'll C my my back from
the mid-range I could around here okay I
get out I get back in and the range low
CL and trade towards that key pivot
level same with for example this other
coin let me Mark it for you let me see
that one there
W this one very similar but at the mid
range myself this one is in the daily
time frame you can see that accumulation
phase right there so yeah but on the mid
range let's see if we break from here
towards that key pivot level 6 69 cents
I would say but if we start to see the
midrange to not hold so if we do some
kind of this consolidation then there
I'm getting out of that trade I'm
looking to reenter at the range lows for
that bounce all right so very clear very
good structures here for Gala View and
tia so with Tia this was probably the
worst tra of the year that I that I took
or one of the worst ones because my
average entry was here around
45ish and well you know it was a great
entry price goes up goes to $9 that's
times two here at this moment I'm hoping
that price is going to go to $12 cuz I
see some momentum here from the previous
days I see also foral I'm hoping price
going to go to $12 it doesn't it
reverses from there goes back down round
trip my entry um and now so far what I'm
waiting is to see if it goes back down
to the range lows where I'm thinking to
even add position there to see if that's
going to be the the correct right to to
the level that I had in mind at the
beginning so yeah possibly I'll even
increase my size here okay that's
something that I'm considering to do
next uh but look here is pretty much
what I'm talking about okay this is the
kind of a structure you have the
accumulation phase then you have here
and this is what I'm expecting to see
next this is the part where I was wrong
and I thought that we were here before
but now H we were you know deviating
back below it so yeah this is something
that I'm expecting to see with Tia Gala
D view um there are probably many more
something I'm expecting to see in the
next few weeks and then last and why not
you have Dogecoin Dogecoin now in the
government so who knows it's uh it's
definitely one that I want to to to be
part of and I talked about this setup a
few weeks ago and I said that is the one
that I felt the least confidence with
because I saw the drop was quite
significantly and we actually are
getting it so far so safe entry would be
getting back Above This range here that
is acting as resistance right now so if
we get back back above 34 cents then you
know we should go to 44 Cent so that's
around 20% pump a bit more even from
there okay something I'll be H very
happy to to see so look guys that would
be actually 25 28% pump okay that is
something that I would be looking to
trade but the only problem that I'm
seeing
here
is this long week there okay now let's
put indicator let's have a look here
because really the 50% level is at 28
cents okay that's the 50% level of that
week so if the daily 50a and the range
lows continue acting as resistance as
it's been doing for the last 5 days or
so it's likely that eventually we drop
at least to 28 cents okay so perhaps
it's something like this what we see
something like that okay
again you could enter here or here if
you want to take the risk and if you
want to be super safe you can enter up
here for a trade depends what you're
looking if you looking to have a spot
back to hold for the next years or if
you are looking to take a a swing trade
that's up to you so that's pretty much
everything guys let's go back to bitcoin
there it is H
95,00 so let's see what it does H
remember key levels you have daily 50
mate there acting a support though I
would like to see something like this
okay give me something like this I'll be
very happy at 9k possibly a bounce from
there and eventually this is just a
range that I'm hoping for a breakout at
the end of it all right and losing
85,000 level
is what I don't want to see I want to
see the level holding because otherwise
we'll drop here we'll drop
towards those highs there at 72,000
right so that's pretty much everything
Bitcoin and shell thank you so much for
watching guys and I'll see you soon